let me tell you about rocks not since
1992 dr. max Bothwell a government of
Kanda scientist has been studying a type
of algae that grows on rocks now the
very unscientific term for that algae is
rocks not because as you can imagine it
looks a lot like snot but scientists
also call it did omus fania Jemma nada
and for decades this algae has been
slamming up riverbeds around the world
the problem with this algae is that it
is a threat to salmon to trout and the
river ecosystems it invades now it turns
out Canada's dr. Bothwell is actually a
world expert in the field so it was no
surprise in 2014 when a reporter
contacted dr. Boswell for a story on the
algae the problem was dr. Boswell wasn't
allowed to speak to the reporter because
the government of the day wouldn't let
him a hundred and ten pages of emails
and sixteen government communication
experts stood in dr. Boswell Swain why
couldn't dr. Boswell speak well we'll
never know for sure but dr. bothwell's
research did suggest that climate change
may have been responsible for the
aggressive algae blooms but who the heck
would want to stifle climate change
information right yes you
laughs to joke because it is laughable
we know that climate change is
suppressed for all sorts of reasons
I saw it firsthand when I was a
university professor we see it when
countries pull out of international
climate agreements like the Kyoto
Protocol and the Paris Accord and we see
it when industry fails to meet its
emissions reduction targets but it's not
just climate change information that's
being stifled so many other scientific
issues are obscured by alternate facts
fake news and other forms of suppression
we've seen it in the United Kingdom
we've seen it in Russia we've seen it in
the United States and until 2015 right
here in Canada in our modern
technological age when our very survival
depends on discovery innovation and
science it is critical absolutely
critical that our scientists are free to
undertake their work free to collaborate
with other scientists free to speak to
the media and free to speak to the
public because after all science is
humanity's best effort at uncovering the
truth about our world about our very
existence every new fact that is
uncovered adds to the growing body of
our collective knowledge scientists must
be free to explore unconventional or
controversial topics they must be free
to challenge the thinking of the day and
they must be free to present
uncomfortable or inconvenient truths
because that's how scientists push
boundaries
and pushing boundaries is after all what
science is all about and here's another
point scientists must be free to fail
because even a failed hypothesis teaches
us something and the best way I can
explain that is through one of my own
adventures but first I've got to take
you back in time it's the early 1900s
and Claire and Vera are roommates and
southern Ontario one evening during the
height of the Spanish flu pandemic the
to attend a lecture together the end of
the evening they head for home and for
bed and the morning Claire calls up to
Vera and says she's going out to
breakfast when she returns a short while
later fear wasn't up she pulls back the
covers and makes the gruesome discovery
Vera was dead when it comes to Spanish
flu those stories are common common of
lightning speed deaths well I was a
professor in my mid 20s when I first
heard those shocking facts and the
scientist in me wanted to know why and
how my curiosity would lead me to a
frozen land and to lead an expedition to
uncover the cause of the 1918 Spanish
flu I wanted to test our current drugs
against one of history's deadliest
diseases I hoped we could make a flu
vaccine that would be effective against
the virus and mutation of it should it
ever return
and so I led a team or research team of
17 men from Canada Norway the United
Kingdom and the United States to the
Svalbard Islands
the Arctic Ocean these islands are
between Norway and the North Pole we
exhumed six bodies who had died of
Spanish flu and were buried in the
permafrost and we hoped the frozen
ground would preserve the body and the
virus now I know what you're all waiting
for that big scientific payoff but my
science story doesn't have that
spectacular Hollywood ending most don't
truth is we didn't find the virus but we
did develop new techniques to safely
exhume bodies that might contain virus
we did develop new techniques to safely
remove tissue that might contain virus
and we developed new safety protocols to
protect our research team and the nearby
community we made important
contributions to science even though the
contributions we made we're not the ones
originally intended in science attempts
fail results proved inconclusive and
theories don't pan out in science
research builds upon the work and
knowledge of others or by seeing further
by standing on the shoulders of giants
to paraphrase Newton the point is
scientists must be free to choose what
they want to explore what they are
passionate about and they must be free
to report their findings you heard me
say that respect for science started to
improve in Canada in 2015 how did we get
here what lessons might we have to share
well it actually goes back to my time as
a professor I watched while agents
these governments and industries around
the world suppress information on
climate change it infuriated me it kept
me up at night
how could politicians twist scientific
fact for partisan gain so I did what
anyone appalled by politics would do I
ran for office and I won I thought I
would use my new platform to talk about
the importance of science it quickly
became a fight for the freedom of
science after all I was a scientist I
came from the world under attack and I
had personally felt the outrage I could
be a voice for those who are being
silenced but I quickly learned that
scientists were nervous even afraid to
talk to me one government scientist a
friend of mine will call a McPherson was
concerned about the impact government
policies were having on his research and
the state of science deteriorating in
Canada he was so concerned he wrote to
me from his wife's email account because
he was afraid of phone call could be
traced he wanted me to phone his wife's
cell phone so that call couldn't be
traced I only wish I were kidding it
quickly brought what was happening in
Canada and to sharp focus for me how
could my friend of 20 years be that
afraid to talk to me so I did what I
could at the time I listened and I
shared what I learned with my friend in
Parliament a man who was interested in
all
environment science technology
innovation and then the 2015 election
rolled around and our party won and we
formed government and that friend of
mine is now the Prime Minister of Canada
Justin Trudeau and he asked if I would
serve as his minister of science
together with the rest of the government
we are working hard to restore science
to its rightful place I will never
forget that day in December 2015 when I
proudly stood in Parliament and
proclaimed the war on science is now
over
and I've worked hard to back up those
words with actions we've had many
successes there's still more work to do
because we're building this culture
shift but we want our government
scientists to talk to the media talk to
the public it'll take time but we are
committed after all
Canada is seen as a beacon for science
internationally and we want to send a
message that you do not mess with
something so fundamental so precious as
science so for dr. Boswell for Clare and
Vera for McPherson and all those other
voices if you see that science is being
stifled suppressed or attack speak up if
you see that scientists are being
silenced speak up we must hold our
leaders to account whether that is by
exercising our right to vote whether is
by penning an op-ed in a newspaper or by
starting a conversation on social media
it is our collective voice that will
ensure the freedom of science and after
all science is for everyone and it will
lead to a better brighter bolder future
for us all thank you
[Applause]